i was in l.a this last week and i was
given the talk
and i decided to open up my message in a
completely different way
on wednesday night we had a dinner with
one of our lawyers entertainment lawyer
solid guy we went to cross stations
great conversation
anytime i go to dinner with a lawyer i i
have a time clock where i said at 45
minutes i'm going to say i got an
emergency call we got to go it's been
great seeing you but this is
some money that way two and a half hours
later we're having a blast funny guy and
he's a badass
and uh so we're sitting there having
said pat you won't believe it you know i
just uh my house in toluca lake two
thousand square feet three bedrooms
right in outside of van nuys like to
luca lake chandler he says 1.8 million
dollars he says i can't even believe it
he says how can you live in a one point
who can't afford a 1.8 million dollar
house three bedrooms so i go when i'm
giving this speech at uh santa monica i
went to santa monica and i spoke at
montebello and at granada hills so
here's how i opened it up
so i got a question for you guys i said
raise your hand
if you have no plans of leaving
california in the next three to five
years okay i'm probably just looking at
me like what as let me ask this question
one more time
raise your hand if you have no plans of
leaving the states you love in the next
three to five years
seventy percent of hands go up that's
seventy percent is to me it's low i
thought it was going to be higher they
have no plan no plans of leaving in the
next three to five how many people in
the room by the way 400 people so okay
300 people are not leaving dude so 300
people are not leaving so i said raise
your hand and for the first time in your
life you're actually considering leaving
the state of california 30 or leave the
room i'm like okay interesting 100
people though it's a lot of people so i
set the phone i said can i just speak to
the people that are planning on staying
here yes absolutely i said if you're
staying in california what you're
telling the world
is you like being part of the state that
has the highest gas prices okay you're
okay with that you're saying you're okay
with being in the state that has the
highest state taxes period you're okay
with that you're saying you don't mind
being in a state with the highest all in
taxes you're okay with that you're
saying you don't mind being in a state
that has the highest homelessness in
america you're okay with that i said do
you want me to continue you don't mind
having the most by the way this friday
they're announcing masks are coming back
in l.a just so you know i said you don't
have mine stop this is this is in l.a
you can't see that you don't mind the
fact that you're overly regulated
controlled everyone's telling you
everything you need to be doing you're
okay with that right i said do you still
planning on staying here their hands
weren't yep we're still planning on
staying i said no problem then if you're
planning on staying here why don't we do
a little bit of math together let's say
sure let's do it i said a friend of mine
had a dinner with two nights ago
he said he just sold his 2 000 square
foot house barely 2 000 square feet
three bedroom two bathroom for 1.8
million dollars i said do we have a
realtor here lady stands up i said can
you help me do math here together yes if
i'm buying a 1.8 million dollar house
that's only 2 000 square feet barely in
this three bedroom if i got a family of
four i can barely live in this place
how much of a down payment do i need to
put on this 1.8 million dollar house she
says 10 minimum i said what's 10 of 1.8
million 180. how many middle americans
in california have 180 thousand dollars
not a lot but let's just say you got it
so you put 180 000 down that 1.8 now
you're financing what 1.62 i said can
you tell me what's a mortgage payment on
1.62 she says roughly 12 thousand
dollars pni everything includes that's a
perfect fine i said this 12 thousand
dollars i make is it pre-tax money or
after-tax money she says that's
after-tax money so what do i need to
make pre-tax
you need to she says around twenty
thousand dollars to a four twelve
thousand dollars i said perfect i said
is everyone tracking they're like we're
tracking i said perfect
what is the number typically
you're only supposed to spend per month
on your mortgage payment isn't it
supposed to be a third yeah it's
supposed to be a third
so for eight two thousand square foot
house that's only three bedroom if you
need to make 20 grand pre-tax money what
do you need to make to be able to afford
a third of a go into mortgage payment
they said sixty thousand dollars i said
what's that times twelve seven twenty i
said how many guys are gonna make 720 in
california the next three to five years
i said now let me ask you this how many
are still planning on staying in the
state of california you should see what
happened i said how many of you just
based on that are open to the idea of
leaving the state in the next three to
five years you know what happened what
happened of the 70 percent half of them
raised their hands and they said that's
just not sustainable huh i said then let
me speak to the other guys that are
planning on staying here how the hell
are you going to get to 7 720 tell me
i'm curious yeah okay so i really wanted
the numbers just don't make sense i mean
you know the median
income in this country is 50 grand and
i'm talking about making 700 grand
here's what's the gap is ridiculous and
on top of that at all of this inflation
add all of this stuff that's going on
how are you gonna be ready for this i
don't understand how people in
california survive well i mean why are
you guys looking at me um by the way the
weather's great yeah yeah and the rams
just won the super bowl even on top of
that too it just the the pressure that
the the federal government did with the
lockdowns in the state specifically in
california i mean they they just ruined
the middle class and then the inflation
right after i mean
it's the whole like who who gets to
judge an essential business you know and
then you look at states like this great
state of florida and desantis who i hope
is president one day and um texas like
they incentivize small businesses and
you know and that's what we should be
doing rather than letting these you know
conglomerate huge corporations just
swallow up the the small man like it
sucks so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]